was it like working on the remake of the
longest yard with adam sandler you have
any funny adam sandler stories
adam's got a whole beautiful group that
he works with and
it's all in
his world and his guys and and wonderful
people i kind of was a little unsure of
the whole journey
um
until the day
that's you know because i just
you know i just trying to do
something with the character and i think
everybody
wanted it to be a little more middle of
the road and and i got that that's you
know that's their choice their movie
and the whole thing
the best day that i had on all of the
longest year and i had a lot of good
days come on i'm playing a football
player i'm a football fan it was just a
lot of fun
i did walk up when when the camera was
rolling and you had these like 300 pound
guys in front of you you know when when
the stunt quarterback was not in going
literally walking down the line to like
romanowski and goldberg and going hey
hey
screen actors kill s-a-g not nfl i'm in
i'm in the game now um
but my son sam who was like 11 at the
time
came to uh
my wife kimmy brought him to santa fe
where we were shooting the prison stuff
and sam was with me and just kind of you
know looking around at the enormity of
it and
a golf cart pulled up
adam was in the golf cart he was by
himself slammed on the brakes he was
like because
we were talking about us and my son
sam's going to come visit slammed on the
brakes he was like you sam sam said yeah
he goes come on we got stuff to do
put him on a golf cart took off
i saw sam about 45 minutes later he just
took him everywhere took him on in video
village showed him one and took him on
the scene the sweetest guy in the world
he brought him back and i was like
i love you adam sandler you know who
doesn't
for that moment right there what a great
moment
hey guys i'm tom welling i used to play
clark kent on smallville i'm michael
rosenbaum i used to play lex luthor on
smallville join us every week as we go
back
way back i'm excited i know are you
can't wait join tom welling and michael
rosenbaum every week as they rewind
every episode of smallville and discuss
their experiences with friends fans and
co-stars talkville the ultimate
smallville podcast
you